Game of Thrones game of crime it is it's
the last season and I know that you are
a super fan it's true yet last season
the last season starts up this I'm here
to promote my own show and all I want to
do throw my Game of Thrones yeah it's um
let's just say you're on game of yeah
you know what I am yeah yeah poor Game
of Thrones doesn't get enough it really
hasn't it again it just feels very
strange that this month is the beginning
of the end of Game of Thrones and it's
the end of Avengers and game like that
whole thing like these two gigantic
franchises are coming to a close and
that to me feels it feels sad but it
also feels very hopeful because it we
don't know what the next gigantic
pop-culture thing that will be out there
that will take over we don't know what
that's gonna be you know so what I'm
saying is we don't know somewhere
sitting in a Starbucks or you know on
his his or her blog is the person
creating the next thing that we can't
see it yet right now it's an it's an
compelling thought right now in the
world someone is hatching something
that's gonna change everything but we
don't know what it is and it's something
that sounds ridiculous
but then we'll be amazing so someone is
going what if baked goods got wizard
powers we're like what don't fight with
spells and then cut to 20 years in the
future oh my god cupcake battles gone
is this gonna be amazing I can't believe
it I don't know who's gonna die it's
either gonna be the fudge one with the
vanilla fulfilling or is gonna be the
Bello one with the budget oh and they
always mess with you you don't know
who's gonna do it
it is true that afterwards everybody
afterwards people just accept what is it
yeah what is it is it people with swords
and is it
dragons sort of but also we're throwing
zombies in there zombies and they're
waiting overthrown and you'd say it
sounds a little muddled to me biggest
thing ever biggest thing and then
there's also crazy sex there's dragons
and zombies and then the most insane sex
scenes in the middle of all of it and
we're gonna make it work yeah I remember
watching hearing about it and being like
that seems kind of fun and silly and
watching the first one and feeling like
this is going to be my guilty pleasure
because it's like dragons like I'm a
grown man what am i watching the dragons
and swords for also then we trace the
only porn I'm allowed to be watching
with my wife my wife comes in the room
and she goes breasts and I go game
[Applause]
you can like no he's these breasts are
in to go to the plot I hate it CDs this
decides who will win and by the way but
it's not a guilty pleasure the people
the people are arguing who will this is
like March Madness the level of my wife
is in a bracket group and they every
week they watch showed say who will die
they got a predict who will die who will
lose a limb who would like it and it's
it is so and she agonizes over who will
be in my bracket cuz you know you want
to think well Peter Dinklage will make
it all the way but then he got no wait a
minute
this show loves to dangle a character
like there's no way they'll dye it and
then they die so hang on maybe he will
die or maybe you know maybe sir she'll
been there no there's no way cuz she's
so evil but there's no love to do it so
it's all it's it's it's it is nerd mind
free and level red
[Applause]